today's news is going to be very tough
for families with mortgages up and down
the country for businesses with loans
but there is a global economic crisis
the IMF the international monetary funds
say a third of the world's economy is
now in recession and the best thing the
government can do if we want to bring
down these rises in interest rates is to
show that we're bringing down our debt
families up and down the country have to
balance their Accounts at home and we
must do the same as a government but the
evidence is very clear that there is a
very significant UK component to this
and that your party Bear's
responsibility for this
but on the steps of Downing Street the
Prime Minister recognize that and said
that he was there to fix that and when I
became Chancellor within a couple of
days I reversed the measures in the mini
budget so we're taking the difficult
decisions at the top of our mind our
families businesses people are worried
about jobs about bills to pay we want to
do what we can to help them but we
recognize the biggest single thing we
can do is to help the bank of England
bring down inflation and the bank is
taking its measures which it's announced
today but the government also has to
play our part by producing national
accounts that balance so that we can
show people that in the end we have
sound money in this country we're
bringing down debt and we're doing the
same things that we're asking families
to do up and down the country
we have got migrants in this country so
desperate they are writing letters in
bottles and throwing them over the fence
at processing centers and migrants being
abandoned on the Streets of London
this government has lost control of
migration hasn't it
well this government is proud that we as
a country have a long tradition of
showing compassion to people who seek
Asylum from overseas we have a system
that isn't working and it's got
particularly bad in the last couple of
years you look at the numbers of Small
Boat Crossings they've shot up in the
last few years and we are determined to
grip that problem and we know the
electorate will hold us accountable for
doing so but I can assure you that is a
number one priority for the Prime
Minister for me for the Home Secretary
to make sure that we get the situation
under control and then we're able to
show everyone who comes to this country
uh the kind of compassion that we're
proud to do is Brits a lot of people are
asking today why isn't the Home
Secretary out doing interviews like you
are
well the Home Secretary did a number of
public appearances this week in
Parliament she's you know she's been
prepared to face the music and why not
today well she's been prepared to face
the music as I say this week um and uh
I'm sure you'll continue to have a
chance to ask her questions